taste them how are you man
i'm doing well thanks how are you i'm
doing great congratulations it was great
to see you play today
when when did you know you were going to
be the starter
um a pretty good idea
monday monday night
what what did coach tell you
well i didn't talk to coach
um just didn't talk to coach but had a
few few conversations with
my physician coach
yeah i knew i was going to go early in
the week
what was the best advice you got this
week and who was it from
great question
man i i think um
i'm trying to think i i think i spent so
much time with drew this week preparing
for the game um and and he was was so
great
um
i would say maybe the best advice that i
received was
you know
being patient letting the game come to
you and
not feeling that
i need to press in any way
and make the plays when they come your
way
what grade would you give yourself for
today
um
i i don't know i haven't seen the film
yet um
at first glance honestly i was happy
with the game you know i'm disappointed
of the fumble
um and i feel like
that was my my biggest indicator you
know going into the game is make sure
man we take care of the ball
and overall we did that and again i was
disappointed on the uh the fumble that i
had
so so maybe it'd be b-plus
with that what did sean have to say to
you afterward
you know he didn't have to say anything
he uh
he was the second person i saw as i got
in the locker room after mrs benson and
uh sean just came and gave me a big hug
what did mrs benson say
she just said she's so proud of me and i
don't know if you know mrs benson but
she's she's the greatest
gave me a big hug and
a kiss on the cheek
and
man i felt a lot of love and support
from
everyone inside this building um in so
many outside as well and i'm sorry i
interrupted you what did sean say after
he came over and gave you a hug
he just gave me a big hug
just gave me a big hug and said congrats
and uh
that was that was it give me the one
thing that you'll remember above all
else 50 years from now about your first
start in the nfl
and i will say just just the
the love that i felt
from those closest to me it's been
overwhelming in a in a very positive way
the number of texts the number of people
that have reached out to me saying
prayers for me my family
um it's been a very humbling week in
that in that regard and
i'll remember
i remember all that i remember all the
conversations and that i had with my
teammates in the locker room after
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports